Well first we need to find the population standard deviation, which is about
1.7078. And remember, our sample size is 2. So according to the center limit
theorem, this standard deviation of this distribution Is sigma divided by route
N which is one point seven zero seven eight, divided by the square of two and
this is about one point two zero seven six. It's okay if you round it. And you
can even find that yourself by brute force since the population only consists of
six values. So you could take all samples, one, one, one two, one three, one
four, one five, one six, two one, two, two, two three, two four, blah, blah,
blah and then you can find the mean of each sample of size two and then find the
standard deviation. Of that data set, consisting of all the means, and you'll
get this number. But, we already know, because of the central limit theorem, we
can find this number just by dividing the population center deviation by root n.